In September after a CT scan, I was told it appeared. I was in remission from a
very cancer yesterday at a follow-up PET scan. More cancer was found. I meet with
the oncologist tomorrow. Any recommendations or questions to ask? I do not know
what she'll recommend. Cancer was found around the liver. So yeah, this is why
I've said for decades that CT scan and PET scans are great and they are a
gold standard. Still, they're not going to show there's any cancer if it's
under three billion cells large. Meeting that you could have cancer that's two
billion cells large, but it doesn't show on the CT scan or on the PET scan and
you're giving it a clean bill of health. That's why you just never, you know, I hate to
be a, I'm not being a pessimist, I'm just being a realist. I mean, you should
just never assume that you're cancer-free. I mean, you should just shoot it. You
should just assume that, hey, even if you don't have cancer, you know, you've never
been diagnosed, you should assume you have cancer. Then you should be treated
yourself as if because it's just true. So, and you know, and I'm not, you know, not
saying you ever stopped doing anything that you were doing beforehand, but
there's, you know, there's been times where that has happened where people thought
they were, you know, cancer-free, so they stopped doing everything, you know,
they can't put a quote, quote, quote, came back with a bed that's where it was
never really covered. It really, really is ever really good and you have to keep
treating as if that's the wisest thing to do. I don't. I personally, you know, I feel
like I've been in a revision and I wax off on my diet more than anything, and I
keep taking my supplements and I keep doing the right every day. Horrible was my
diet. I've always been horrible at my diet. And that's not a good thing. And I'm
reminded, you know, every once in a while that I need to get better, especially when I
have got paid again, I need to get better, be more disciplined. I have to be
praying for that. So any recommendations or questions to ask, I would just hear
them out, see what they say, and then just polite. They say thank you very much. I
get to get back to it. I'm, you know, I'm gonna pray about this and decide what I
want to do. So, you know, they may, I don't, I don't have your chart up. I don't
remember what their additional recommendations, but what do they have?
They have really three tools, you know, you know, they probably will not do
radiation, but they may want to do biopsy. I wouldn't recommend doing that, but they
may want to do chemotherapy. So, and then you say, okay, well, let me think about
it and pray about it on the back to you. And do some of that and some research and
certainly can have conversation with me and we can talk about it too when we're
looking at the scans.